hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday you already know
what's going on it's another dev stream
recap for you all so let's get started
so first up Dominion ranked is gonna be
released it's gonna be single pick only
just like brawls except it's gonna be a
4 V 4 just like normal Dominion no gear
stats no special rewards because it
doesn't include tournaments your rank
will be based off of if you win or lose
and how you've all performed in that
match and the quitter penalty still
applies now I do like this some of the
people disagreed with it on the reddit
post I like the fact that you won't get
rewards that means that your that we
might potentially start seeing rewards
after the season ends and on top of that
that also means that there's gonna be no
tournament queuing for dual obviously if
any of you play the dual tournament you
queue up with like 8 to 32 of different
people you wait to all the matches are
done that could take hours just to do a
match or didn't you'll complete a entire
tournament now all you have to do is
queue up for 4 with your team queue up
against another team win or lose matches
over then you queue up with another one
you don't sit in a tournament and you
wait for an hour it's just one and done
you're out which i think is really good
it keeps the pace moving and it might
actually make people play the game a lot
more next up the new content of the week
is elite outfits this is the first type
of content we've gotten of the week and
stuff like that since the beginning of
season 4 obviously because season 4
released there was a lot of stuff we
still had to go through and a lot of
other things that they talked about we
haven't gotten a content of the week yet
once again its elite outfits they're 7k
I don't feel like showing you the video
it's too long it's like 3 minutes long
I'll probably show like a quick brief
shot of what all the outfits look like
probably while I'm talking but I'm not
gonna show the whole 3 minutes that's
just gonna be wasting of your time and I
don't want to keep you guys waited I
don't want to keep you guys waiting
longer than you have to next up is the
new event order this weekend it's going
to be called dominant Slayer as a
community perform as many takedowns as
you can in all modes pvp and PVE i the
reward is going to be 2 scavenger crates
as opposed to the 2000 steal that I
normally thought we got and then lastly
to end this is going to be a summary of
the live patch 1.15 point one that
actually is going to be released today
for everyone I believe now I talked a
little bit about this last week it had
to do with the shaman nerf these are
included as well if you didn't read the
if you didn't watch that video
don't worry I'm gonna cover up
everything most of the general stuff in
this so let's get started first up
peacekeepers own attack cancel recovery
time is being increased by 200
milliseconds the reason they did that is
because peacekeeper would get a revenge
and then she would constantly do her
zone attack and cancel it and zone
attack and cancel it because it was
almost an instantaneous attack and you
could just cancel it with ease and just
get constant damage so there's gonna be
a 200 millisecond brief period before
you can do it again after you cancel it
to prevent you from just getting
absolutely melted by it during revenge
most of these are bug fixes but to start
off Valkyrie is getting a issue resolved
that would cause her shoulder pin to
sometimes be blocked in situations where
it shouldn't you go key has an issue
resolving causing the range of demons
brace to be shorter than expected and
gladiator resolved an issue causing the
causing him to be bumped by his opponent
while throwing him against the wall and
then to end we have the shaman nerfs
once again I will go over those if you
didn't read those
so to start shamans Bobcats rage
swiftness and pounce are gonna be
reduced to 20 damage as opposed to the
original 25 so that is Bobcats rage
Wildcats swiftness and Wildcats pounce
on top of that her basic heavy opener
damage is being reduced to 27 from 33
Wildcats rage and normal blocked
recoveries are also being increased by
an extra 100 milliseconds and then to
end is a bug fix for her shaman can no
longer switch targets during the running
portion of wild cats rage predators
hunger or predators mercy before shaman
was able to start running at one target
then whip around and actually attack a
different one this is no longer possible
so if that was an issue or you had a
grip against that there it is
those are the shaman nerves personally I
don't think this is enough I still think
she might be a little bit of a problem
on console PC I don't really play her
too much on PC I can't really speak for
myself though but on console I can
definitely say that she is a big force
to be reckoned with
and I don't know if these are gonna stop
it will have to play her along with
these a little bit more maybe she'll
need more nerfs who knows we'll just
have to see once again guys that is
going to be the end of this data stream
recap I hope you guys did enjoy I like
the video if you did it really does help
me out and shows that you do support me
subscribe if you're new I cover the news
the leaks the discussion on for honor
and while you're at it hit the bell
right next to it it's not going to hurt
- just hit it and you could be notified
whenever I post the video or if I post
on the on the community tab I'm gonna
try to start using that a lot more I
said I was going to and I just didn't
I'm going to be using that a lot more
trust me thank you all guys for the
support on my recent videos as well you
guys are the best
and with that guys two most recent
videos of popping up on screen hope you
have a great rest of your day and your
weekend and peace out